entspannt ist jetzt wirklich zu einer
art hassfigur geworden oder wie kann man
das natürlich als genau also als nicht
nur als person sondern in der funktion
beim amt der sänger hatte als
gesundheitsminister die perfekte
projektionsfläche für alle die mit
diesem corona maßnahme nicht
einverstanden sind sondern die dann
darüber hinaus sich auch radikalisieren
die dann ja irgendwelche irgendwelche
verschwörungstheorien anhängen die sich
immer weiter immer weiter hinein
steigern in etwas und die dann glauben
jens spahn würde sie zum impfen zwingen
zwangs schippen und dergleichen also da
ist er tatsächlich einen nebeneingang
merkel
christian drosten und bill gates
wahrscheinlich gehört zu den zu den
leuten die da am ehesten eine
projektionsfläche abgeben für diese
leute die haben ja gerade im interview
herr der als trotzdem sehr distanziert
relativ gefasst ich würde möchte jetzt
nicht sagen emotionslos aber schon wie
gesagt relativ distanziert gibt es für
jemanden der so eine haltung hat
überhaupt noch die möglichkeit die
menschen mehr einzufangen
ich glaube dass das vom radikalisierung
grad der einzelnen leute abhängt für den
politiker ist das glaube ich auf so
normal kann veranstaltung sehr sehr
schwer wenn die leute sich da in der
masse ein finden sich gegenseitig
hochschaukeln schein und hetzen und
dergleichen die wollen dann tatsächlich
nur ihren hass loswerden auf diese
projektionsfläche die er abgibt
das ist sehr sehr schwer mit denen dann
ins gespräch zu kommen
diese leute wieder einzufangen und ja
irgendwie auf den pfad der vernunft
gleichen zurückzuführen das ist glaube
ich eher die aufgabe von verwandten von
freunden dieser leute die dir vielleicht
mit einem ruhigen moment beiseite nehmen
und denen zu hören was wir ansonsten so
für probleme in deren umfeld sind denn
das was diese leute darum schreien
das sind ja das sind nur vorgeschobene
sachen also das ist die diese verrückten
verschwörungstheorien die sich
hineinsteigern
die haben andere ursachen die haben
andere die leiden möglicherweise unter
den einschränkungen dieser kroner
maßnahmen haben vielleicht ihren job
verloren leiden darunter dass die kinder
den ganzen tag betreuen müssen weil die
nicht in die kita oder schule können und
ja steigern sich dann wenn sie sich das
hat ja ein spanier auch angesprochen
wenn sie sich in ihren whatsapp oder
facebook gruppen gegenseitig
hochschaukeln steigern sich dann daran
einen bahrain den 1
politiker auf einer
wahlkampfveranstaltung kaum aufbrechen
kaum erklären kann
nichtsdestotrotz ist natürlich wichtig
dass er zeigt ja macht ein
gesprächsangebot als politiker hört
diesen leuten trotzdem zu das ist für
die fans da vielleicht auch noch von den
bildern nicht zu sehr täuschen lassen
in bottrop war dass diese leute die da
rumschreien diese 20 jahren keine ahnung
wie viele leute das waren aber so viel
wahnsinnig es waren auch genügend leute
da die geklatscht haben als er von der
maske sprach insofern ist dieses
gesprächsangebot diese dieses ja dieses
zeigen dass er mit den leuten
diskutieren kann über die maßnahmen
durchaus auch an die gerichtet die eben
zu sehen und nicht die die dann mit der
trillerpfeife stehen über die darum wie
hasserfüllt irgendwas hetzen